[Música]
ese soy yo lo pinto hernando tejada
mi mamá y mi papá me decían que cuando
yo era pequeño
lo que más me gustaba
no era ir a la finca pasar el fin de
semana
seguro disfrutado muchísimo
sino que me gusta que llegará la hora
del regreso
y yo esperaba que se les hiciera tarde
no para jugar más
sino por lo que iba a pasar en el camino
mi papá
maneja muy despacio
yo lo que les estoy diciendo lo que
cuando ven en el carro y él va manejando
yo puedo ver como florecen las plantas
en el camino
en serio es verdad y hace trancón o sea
la amiga de la cruda de seguro nos
montaría y llegaríamos mucho más rápido
a cali pero la verdad es el regreso por
la carretera al mar cuando uno va
bajando y pasa la vuelta del cerezo se
encuentra con una curva que es
espectacular y nunca la va a poder sacar
de mi corazón y es una curva en la que
pasa esto
en la ciudad
sé de la ciudad que no viene bajando
y de momento todo calle al frente y yo
lo que hago dice mi mamá que saltando
yo me quedaba aterrado
porque todo inmediatamente me emocionaba
y comenzaba a decir
ni calles ni calles ni calles ni acá ni
eran italianni's vida la que yo estoy
viendo a donde yo iba acabo de pasar un
fin de semana espectacular montando con
mi caballo plan y no dándole de comer a
los animalitos jugando metiéndome al río
embarrando todas las cosas que hacemos
en las fincas
pero s
en su momento
en el cual yo era la ciudad era un mejor
momento del viaje y no solamente por lo
que significaba sino por lo que iba a
significar yo estoy en la universidad de
san buenaventura y la cafetería
tiene una vista de cali bueno ahora ya
no está tan poder como antes porque hay
muchos más edificios pero se veía todo
cal y luego yo me fui a vivir a españa y
me parecía espectacular también las
luces de las ciudades
cuando yo crecí
y ya podían viajar en avión de la calle
de noche de objetivos siempre del volver
de noche porque llegar a calidad de
noche cuando el avión sigue derecho y se
devuelve y uno de aquí siempre yo
siempre pide la ventana del lado
izquierdo porque cuando se devuelve un
avión aunque hay una vuelta muy larga
uno comienza a ver toda la ciudad y en
barcelona me pasaba lo contrario podía
la ventana del lado derecho porque la
buenas o lo contrario se hasta el fondo
y después será la próxima el
aproximamiento se hace por toda la costa
y se ve toda barcelona pero más allá de
eso y en esa foto esta foto de aquí esas
luces
en ese momento están haciendo a alguien
seguro
algunos de los amigos está tomando una
foto hay alguien encerrado buscando
salir
o hay una mujer apretando sea la falda o
hay algún muerto de miedo
y todo lo que hemos hablado aquí allí
está la ciudad violenta
la ciudad con sus contrastes que da vida
y la quita una ciudad donde siempre
haber dinámicas y nunca haber una paz
tranquila sino que siempre hacen la
propia existencia del ser humano en
sociedad quiero que pase porque me
cambió pues me está line motiva mi cali
me llena de orgullo yo comencé a
estudiar y soy abogado vengo de familia
de abogados de abogados y de políticos
pero soy abogado y además de abogado soy
profesor y entonces comienzo a
actualizar y entonces que que hace un
abogado y qué hace un profesor hacemos
casi lo mismo
es necesario resolver problemas y
mejorar la condición de vida de las
personas
eso es el compromiso no más intentar ser
buenos seres humanos pero la unidad es
la ciudad la ciudad ese espacio donde
convivimos coexistimos ese espacio donde
hombres y mujeres
tienen que aprender a vivir
tranquilamente pero la ciudad de la que
yo hablo me lleva a contrastes como soy
profesor un día comenzó en mi clase
diciendo
buenos días muchachos yo soy un
pesimista optimista
a espaldas centre en tablero
que me guste este mundo callado volvió
otra vez al talento bueno ya esté lo que
pasa entonces se tiene un problema
ya tengo muchos problemas pero tuve
problemas están diciendo usted es que
usted tiene una contradicción lo claro
si yo no vivo en contradicciones
permanentemente no presenciar yo lo que
el cual es el problema es que uno no
puede ser pesimista y optimista a la vez
o uno es pesimista o es optimista uno de
dos yo aquí pensando en mí
fue un muchacho viene del colegio seguro
va a tener que llevarse esta clase y que
la recuerde siempre pero bueno yo soy
pesimista por esa ciudad llena de
problemas por la corrupción por el
machismo por todas las dinámicas de la
no inclusión tengo problemas con la
desigualdad social tengo problemas con
la injusticia tengo problemas con cómo
funcionan las cosas precisamente con
esos problemas voy a cambiar todo
iniciática en foto agosto encimista pero
soy pesimista por ese lado pero yo soy
un pesimista optimista porque cada vez
que lleva un salón o cada vez que tiene
un espacio como esto lo veo a todos
ustedes y sé que ustedes son buenas
personas y sé que ustedes pueden cambiar
lo que está pasando por eso me encanta
que se amarre en la falda porque allí
está lo que debemos hacer
pesimismo 3000 pesimista sí pero
optimista porque tenemos nuevas
generaciones ayudados estudiantes o
personas que vuelven a pensar las cosas
a repensar pero más que el pesimista le
decía el estudiante soy realista
realista y tenemos otro problema porque
como hacen que la realidad no nos vamos
a meter en filosofía terminamos en una
conclusión muy interesante
no hay una realidad cada uno vivimos
nuestra propia realidad entonces el
realista es el que conoce su realidad y
salió a las manos de las realidades de
los demás ese realismo me llevó
justamente a hablar lo que queríamos
tratar aquí y es cómo vamos a hacer si
estamos hablando de una ciudad llena de
problemas yo me acordé del mito de
pandora se acuerdan del mito de pandora
que tiene una caja donde los dioses para
jugar con ella
en esa cajita en esa caja van todos los
males del mundo y la esperanza y que
cuando pandora ahora en la caja salen
todos los males y la ciudad se convierte
como la que tenemos pero cuando cierra
la caja se queda la esperanza encerrada
por lo que necesitábamos sacar es
justamente la esperanza una esperanza
que es parte de la ilusión cuando
ustedes comienzan a buscar el concepto
ilusión van a encontrar que es la
esperanza pero justamente en esa ilusión
cuando uno comienza a tratar de entender
la palabra ilusión se puede llevar una
contradicción porque es la primera el
primer concepto de ilusión es el de la
ilusión visual el del engaño de la
sociedad el segundo concepto de una
ilusión si es la esperanza
entonces no me puedo ir con la primera
impresión porque si me quedo en la
primera impresión estaría viendo una
ilusión visual
pero realmente yo necesito entender la
ilusión como como la esperanza que sé
que podemos encontrar toda pasar aquí
pueden ser la ilusión una fuerza
transformadora del mundo pues claro
si la ilusión me lleva a la esperanza
pues la ilusión puede ser una forma una
fuerza transformadora del mundo y además
porque dentro del concepto
de esperanza está el deseo quien deseo
es aquello que te apetece lo que yo
quiero y yo quiero una ciudad donde
todos podamos vivir en paz donde todos
podamos vivir tranquilamente y que
seamos tolerantes los unos con los otros
pero ese deseo me lleva justamente a
pensar desde cali y como hoy para poder
hablar de ese tema y justamente el tema
que supuestamente tenía que hablar con
ustedes hoy es que los personajes
detalles han sido muchísimos tenemos por
ejemplo perdón
andrés caicedo todo el mundo lo conoce
riverita
el peluquero que mientras iba cortando
el pelo contando historias
el loco guerra cuidando bendiciones iba
saludando a la gente por cuando se ponía
en mal genio comenzada tiras madrazos
también y los nuevos personajes de cali
que uno solo se encuentra por la calle
hay otro también el coronel batata que
esos son personajes pero porque a
traerles tantos hombres aquí
más vale para lo que vinimos es cierto
pues también tenemos dos de los
personajes de cali que son dos ejemplos
de las mujeres
caleñas desde esa tradición del cali
viejo y cali viejo porque se acerca la
feria que va a pasar acá hoy no vamos a
hablar de un par arrebato aunque yo sé
que a carlos le gustaría todo vamos
directamente a jovita
súbita tenía la falda bien puesta y no
voy a hablar de la jovita loca porque
quedaríamos en la ilusión que
distorsiona la esperanza justa si bien
es cierto es un personaje que todo el
mundo llamado porque estaba un poquito
chiflada realmente lo que me interesa
rescatar de jovita era que tenía
esperanza que tenía ilusión y justamente
se enfrentaba a un estanque lleno de
miedos pero cuando ella lo veía de una
forma diferente lo sabía enfrentar
entonces jovita que nació en 1910 en
palmira luego se vino para tali y
comenzó a hacerla de la bandera en el
río cali más o menos por donde esa santa
rita santa teresita todo lo que tiene
que ver con centenario entonces juristas
se convierte se convierte en una pieza
clave se convierte
como si fuera la reina del ajedrez y
porque la reina del ajedrez
y eso es pura política porque la reina
del ajedrez porque la reina del ajedrez
se puede mover en todas las direcciones
las demás fichas no lo hacen las demás
fichas cada uno tiene su papel pobre
peón
o la suerte del alfil que se mueve en
diagonal que se puede atrasar la prueba
el asunto es
jovita se movía en todas las direcciones
y tenía la falda bien puesta además
muchas faldas porque las señoras de la
alta sociedad le regalaron sus prendas
sus joyas sus carteras las coronas todo
lo que se utilizaba en esa época
entonces jovita vivía bien vacía
y fuera de eso cuál sería el poder de
jovita que audita podía hablar con los
presidentes
a hablar con los periodistas los
estudiantes la nombrada en la reina
todo el mundo decía que estaba loca pero
tenía posición del club colombia todo el
mundo decía que estaba loca pero lo
invitaron a la inauguración del estadio
pascual guerrero todo el mundo decía que
estaba loca y me invitaron cuando duda
nada más bendiciones desde las tres
cruces todo el mundo decía que estaba
loca pero estaba donde todos quisiéramos
estar
y tiene esa locura
y va acercándose a la gente le decía
señor colonial miret o portal sitio de
san román ponga atención ver quién está
al sitio no hay luz ponga atención
mire que hay gente que necesita azúcar
para hacer las macetas ponga atención y
jovita se convirtió no solamente en la
loca sino también en una mujer
empoderada cosas que uno no sabía y si
lo sabía pues se lo olvida porque
prefiere ser la loca jovita qué va a
pasar con eso miren el entierro de
jovita miren el infierno la plaza de
cayzedo llena de gente yo no conocía
esta foto
mi papá escribió la novela de jovita y
por qué estás abiertas für gonzález que
le escribió en el 72 la biografía de las
ilusiones la historia de jovita yo nunca
había visto esa foto ustedes se imaginan
un entierro de estos para una loca
bueno eso será que la sociedad está loca
esa es la otra mitad después de todo lo
que yo les estoy hablando
jovita vive
porque vive no solamente porque hoy las
estoy reviviendo yo aquí para hablar con
ustedes sino que como personaje talent
yo ha dado
para generar
una tradición de un personaje una mujer
o una mujer aunque lo que ve a todos los
que les estoy contando que hacía y
además una mujer empoderada desde su
ilusión es la de poder servir y hoy
miren cómo está aquí el fernet franco le
tengo la foto famosa unos artistas
ecuatorianos vinieron al museo a la
bienal de arte al mus le hicieron un
cuadro de jean en la quinta la de pongo
que todo el mundo conoce la bernanrdo
tejada la de esteban martínez el amigo
bajar el par del lo de los grafiteros e
iván montoya chulada y una cantidad de
gente que todavía hoy sigue hablando de
jovita como una mujer como una loca como
una persona empoderada con un personaje
de calle por eso yo me siento honrado de
ser el único hombre que habla de hoy he
hecho los ejercicios de vida de
masculinidades he hecho todo lo que
tiene que ver con equidad de género soy
solidario y acepto las diversidades las
diferentes formas de pensar y creo que
eso incluso lleva para esto nos
enfrentamos a un choque de la cultura a
esta cultura y la cultura popular
tenemos que tener y reconocer que a
veces hay otras formas de pensar hay
otras formas de emprender que rompen los
estereotipos si se es o sea no lo puede
hacer te faltó decir que las mujeres
también en la revolución francesa
quedaron los derechos de la mujer y así
la ciudadana y a la pobre te dijo eso la
mataron
la lucha de las mujeres puede entrar al
colegio a la universidad la lucha de las
mujeres para votar y entrar en la
democracia osea que hace falta muchas
personas que emprendan las luchas que
todos ustedes están haciendo hacen falta
más locas porque la sociedad dice esto
lo que usted tiene que hacer necesitamos
la que diga que no y para adelante y
vamos para adentro y de eso se trata
jovita vive aquí en algo fundamental
se acuerdan está dicho que la locura
salva el mundo
ya que la razón no pudo pensar que
intentar eso
seguro a su mamá
el día que no lo dejo la comida lista el
papá ya está loca
pero tenía que hacerlo aunque el
concepto de locura en 1500 era otro no
era justamente el de pensar diferente
entonces
aunque soy un pesimista optimista creo
que ahora sí queda clara la explicación
que soy menos pesimista soy más
optimista pero siempre soy realista todo
lo que va a pasar vivimos un mundo muy
complejo lo que leyó carlos pero creo
que la esperanza puede ser ese es el
motor de trasfondo que transforma el
mundo solamente queda algo que decir
tengo una chiquita divina hermosa tiene
5 años no puede vivir esto aquí porque
está enfermita tiene fiebre anoche
pasamos una noche luchando contra la
fiebre dañando la dándole dolex todo ese
cuento
hoy la cima con este yo quería decirle
eso ya yo quiero que ya se lo quita
yo quiero que ya sea loquita que ya
emprenda esas luchas y aunque ya lo hace
en la casa pero quiero que ya sepa que
nunca se puede perder la esperanza
porque esa esperanza de la forma la que
transforma el mundo entonces perdón lo
que sí hay un poquito más de tiempo pero
quería decirles gracias
[Aplausos]